retrograde phone mate started with a
simple idea a message messages you can
get on the phone while not by the phone
and they took that idea and added the
ability to receive 20 messages on a real
toore tape please leave a message after
the then they took that idea and added
the ability to screen your calls I think
we can all think of a few people we'd
like that function for
that would be enough but they took that
idea another level
further if you're the kind of person who
gets messages and do hope for your sake
that you are phone mate gives you many
ways to enjoy them with the personal
answering machine it's simple saving you
time waiting by the
phone let us know in the comments what
your favorite retro gadgets are and
please subscribe for
one